Prince Harry spent years earning the
title of royal rebel so his marriage to
an American actress well that's totally
on-brand I've always loved new
experiences and were not surprised to
see Megan rewrite the Royal rules sticky
things all at number five Megan in
Harry's very regular and very public
displays of affection it was absolutely
amazing to get to know her as quickly as
I did while it seemed normal to see
newlyweds being googly eyed and overly
affectionate the hand-holding the
smooching and even the gushing I'd be so
proud to be able to introduce my wife to
you totally goes against the Royal norm
she's a breath of fresh air at number
four Megan's long history of feminism
when you and Lily reached out to me I
asked him if I could go an intern at the
UN headquarters the 37 year old Duchess
began advocating for women long before
the Duke entered her world women need a
seat at the table they need an
invitation to be seated there and in
some cases where this isn't available
well then you know what then they need
to create their own table and despite it
being an unprecedented move marrying
into the Royal fan hasn't changed that
one bit women's suffrage is about
feminism but feminism is about fairness
when girls are given the right tools to
succeed they can create incredible
futures not only for themselves but for
all of those around them but Megan
doesn't just talk the talk she walks the
walk or should we say shut their own car
door
girls while attending her first solo
event back in September the Duchess
proved her independence with this simple
move and she turned heads by opting for
crossed legs rather than the traditional
Duchess slant while attending the young
leader Awards with the Queen in our
number three spot Meghan's sometimes
unconventional fashion the Duchess
turned heads just weeks after her
wedding when she wore this pink Carolina
Herrera number to the Queen's official
birthday with bare shoulders on full
display it was perhaps a little more
revealing than I think we used to sing
check out Keith the recorder length
sleeves
in comparison the Queen is known to have
certain preferences that includes new
tights or pantyhose and let's not forget
the time she's skipped the pantyhose and
showed off her killer stems while posing
it up with Harry after announcing their
engagement but it's the non-traditional
touch Meghan added to her wedding gown
that has us all swooning could you see
it the piece of blue fabric that
stitched inside knows my something blue
it's my it's fabric from the dress today
we're on our first date ads but a number
two way Meghan is expected to rewrite
the royal rule book with her parenting
according to a source Meghan Harry want
their kiddos to have as normal a
childhood as possible quote they plan to
spend a considerable amount of time in
their Cotswolds home and Daria will have
a prominent role in their family as the
children's grandmother and get this the
source says they'll even be expected to
do chores and one day have regular jobs
she has subtly done things differently
and finally at number one Meghan is
shaking up a royal holiday tradition
with Meghan by his side Harry is is a
happier person and and together they're
going to take on the world last year
she became the first Theon se to be
invited to spend Christmas with the
royal family and this year it's her mum
getting the Queen's invite a source
tells ET that Doria Ragland is expected
to spend some of the holiday with her
daughter and son-in-law adding quote
dorias quiet dignity and grace at the
Royal Wedding has earned her enormous
respect from Megan's new in-laws
according to the source it's expected
that doriel will receive an invitation
to attend church with the royal family
as for the royal kicker while Kate
Middleton's parents have also been
guests at the morning service when it
comes to accommodations they typically
stay with Kate and William at their home
nearby what do you think of our favorite
royal rebel should we keep calm while
she carries on or is this break in
protocol undignified messages and let us
know
you